E aí
eu
gostaria de começar a fazer uma pergunta
muito muito simples mas que me perseguiu
durante muito tempo
e
umas coisas você já desistiu
é um sonho o trabalho o relacionamento
um curso o livro
a academia
aliás
Malditos pacotes de seis meses e
eu perguntei de 12 academia aqui mas não
mente funciona assim na primeira semana
você vai certinho todos os dias porque
você pagou
e depois o tempo você começa a e duas
três vezes por semana e é cada quinze
dias
depois vai toda a culpa bate
principalmente na segunda-feira depois
do almoço de domingo e por fim
que se der
se interessa eu já paguei duas vezes
outro dia estava de vestido e eu vou
trabalhar na rádio e o texto dessa
propaganda fazia uma outra pergunta
também muito classe
e o que você quer ser quando crescer
e
isso me trouxe várias lembranças porque
eu já que ser engenheiro Eu Já Quis sei
que tempo
e até que isso mano dieta e
aqui outro de avião
e Eu Já Quis Ser design Quase fiz
desenho industrial
eu acabei me tornando O Boticário
engraçado de dentro do banco eu descobri
publicitário nada a ver né mas eu também
já quis ser pintor eu já fiz ser
skatista eu já que esse jogador de
basquete faz a minha altura
bom e até astro do rock que nunca
E você só se observou mas até a mesma
foi mudando drasticamente eu conversei
com o engenheiro e definir como home
Ah pois é o mesmo cara Roberto gay todo
o dinheiro da mãe conseguiu por que que
eu não posso
e o Ato é que eu mudava de opinião pelo
menos uma vez de semana só para não
quebrar o motivo eu simplesmente não
conseguia decidir que com toma
toma mesmo conhecia uma nova profissão
ou alguém que trabalhava naquela área eu
dizia para mim mesmo cara é isso é isso
que eu quero ser achei E aí no começo é
aquela empolgação o que começava quanto
antes elas sobre o olho faca nos dentes
e ainda
e
então me desmotivava tão rápido quando
eu tinha empolgada e a solução mais olho
então era desistir e partícula próxima
ideia
uma palavra que você já deve ter
escutado muito iniciativa
O que você já escutou coisa do tipo olha
você precisa ter mais iniciativa porque
sabe o mercado mercado competitivo
mercado de engolir você precisa ser
sempre o primeiro tem atitudes
vencedoras e tantos outros clichês de
gurus motivação
eu
nunca gostei de esperar as coisas
acontecerem
e também não gostava de depender dos
outros e se irritava eu é só o máximo
por isso é muito
boa porque eu tinha esse ativo
a
tendência ativa realmente é muito bom
faz você se destacar os demais eu
atenção é importante o problema é que eu
começava mais dificilmente
eu terminava
e depois de muito tempo e de vários
projetos inacabados eu percebi que eu
precisava de menos em se ativam e mais
acabar ativa
É isso mesmo tá errado não acabar ativa
começar e terminar alguma coisa
Ah e por que que eu tô falando isso eu
posso ficar vários motivos mas teve
alguns que foram os meus gatinhos de
auto-sabotagem e o primeiro deles é o
Olá eu sou da geração que praticamente
fio a inter
oi Vilma Hotel se formalizar e eu lembro
perfeitamente da primeira vez que eu vou
site na tela do computador
é aquela cena eu vou dormir
se você gostou não é que eu só curtindo
e conectar depois da meia-noite porque a
internet era discada e eu tinha que
economizar
Ah e quem é da época faz lembrar disso
é o mesmo sentimentos agora
mas e quando tem alguns que então cara o
Google é sério eu queria ver tudo eu
queria ler tudo parecia que a minha
mente responde com tanta informação eu
fiz todos os cursos de possíveis
informática da minha cidade eu queria
seu próximo gays pois parecia que quanto
mais alto mais informação tinha mais
distante onde estava
a
má gestão de Gustavo
eu sou o tipo de cara que tem uma
dificuldade
gigantesca de uma ter foco em uma
atividade só eu sou capaz de estar
conversando com alguém de repente olhar
para perguntar do que a gente tá falando
mesmo
é muito comum bastante com isso porque
eu não consigo manter esse foco quando
eu tô trabalho no computador eu tenho
pelo menos umas 10 Abas abertas no
navegador enquanto eu escuto uma música
Eu acho que eu tô pelo menos uns 50 e
outros lá
e
eu também sou um comprador compulsivo
dele
e
olha tem sobre mim
o
último acho que ficou muito bonito lá no
instante sabe eu gosto organizar por
cores e tal e Eu esquento mais
inteligente Quando eu olho para eles e
toda vez que eu recebo a visita até
mesmo pessoas que horas quer emprestar
Ah pois na verdade amor de deus eu to be
an
o Antigamente era muito mais simples
você escolher uma profissão ou você era
médico ou você é advogado ou se é
dinheiro ou ser administradora ordeiro e
hoje eu nem sei quantas faculdades e
cursos estão registrados no Brasil
mas o cara que quer ser surfista por
exemplo e não precisa ser apenas
surfista Hoje ele pode ser graduado em
Tecnologia e Ciência dos urso
o
mesmo esse curso existe
Mas a questão é que a gente vive hoje
uma overdose de informação e muitas
opções acabam nos deixando sem opção ou
incapazes de decidir
o e acontece o seguinte a gente passa
Shake toda hora que está perdendo alguma
coisa importante
e parece que o que a gente sabe nunca é
suficiente e a gente acha que nunca está
pronto para colocar o que já sabemos em
prática
é você ter conhecimento sobre muitas
coisas mas você precisa se aprofundar em
algo ao ponto de conseguir transformar
esse conhecimento e Augusto
e
outra quando o gatilho de auto-sabotagem
estava dentro da minha motivação e aí eu
faço as clássicas perguntas o que te
motiva O que que está tesouro fazer com
que você se identifica
e depois de um tempo eu comecei a
perceber algumas qualidades e
habilidades de e fizeram Caminhar Pela
publicidade pela
é mas só de mim tô sinceramente que eu
escolhi essa carreira pelo coaching
se alguém que você precisa para ser
feliz você precisa fazer o que gosta
você precisa ter para ser o que você faz
na legal a 3D isso levei isso ao pé da
letra mas sem parte é uma grande mentira
e
e parece contraditória
só você já parou para pensar que essas
hora de fazer só gosta Tem tirado
pessoas mimadas que não sabe lidar com
os seus erros suas falhas suas derrotas
egocêntricas frustradas porque não
o que que é
G1
a educação de hoje ela tem trabalhar
seguinte forma 1
se você deve explorar aquilo que te dá
prazer
bom então se é gostoso eu faço
É sim não é gostoso eu não preciso
simplesmente não quero fazer
E aí
Ah pois foi a sua motivação ela não pode
depender apenas está gostando ou não
imagina só capacidade de se motivar
estiver atrelado ao botão voltado e
volátil Quanto é o prazer
E aí
o Zoológico
ele sabe que é
todo trabalho tem as suas coisas chatas
que eu preciso ser
o que Eu odiava as coisas
e toda vez que o desistir de uma projeto
a culpa do câmbio a culpa era dessas
coisas
e a culpa do mesmo
E aí
e eu preciso de geração selfie
e a história que o próprio umbigo
e
depois de um tempo eu comecei a
desenvolver métodos percebendo essas
minhas falhas ou conhecer a pesquisar e
adaptar métodos que pudessem me ajudar a
união todo o meu objetivo e quebrar eles
em pedaços
E aí
E aí que eu pudesse cumprir elas uma uma
uma das coisas que eu descobri que tem
pesado muita s
é extremamente importante porque hoje
tudo que eu faço
precisa ser útil para mais alguém além
de mim
eu fui pessoas no processo n
e o seu compromisso de chegar até o fim
ele aumenta isso é um cria
a e agora Toda vez que eu penso em
desistir eu lembro parece que pode ser
importante para mais alguém mentir
e isso me faz continuar PE
e hoje tem uma larga que mistura
criatividade
a cultura pop
a teologia
a e agora não está pensando em investir
em alguns projetos funcionários sociais
e humanitários essa galera tá usando ver
as camisetas da marca da índia em um
trabalho com as crianças tablets fazem
parte da casta mais baixa da Índia são
considerados impuros Intocáveis aquelas
pessoas que ninguém quer chegar perto
na semana passada acho que sexta-feira
eu e hoje ele já estão no Nepal
hoje eu continuo publicitário
é aquela pergunta o que você
eu não sou o que eu queria ser quando
era criança
felizmente os tomates
eu consegui ser mais e pela de Louis
bellson eu consigo durante o processo de
criação das peças desde a concepção da
estampa até o cliente que não usou na
rua espalhando essas
E aí
e me fazem sentir que eu estou
construindo algo
último que vai além de mim aonde tem
começo meio
o e acaba a chuva obrigado a